can I just ask you a question because we
saw your guitar floating around in space
there what happened to that guitar where
is it because that is a remarkable and
unique guitar it's a Canadian guitar was
made by Larry vay by John Larry veo
Vancouver and I was really pleased to
find it on board the space station it
had been up there since 2001 it has had
70,000 world tours that guitar has been
around the world seventy thousand times
that your guitar is it still up no it
belongs to the space station and it's
been up there and it's still up there
now it is it's part of our psychological
support and it stays up on station for
all the guitar astronaut musicians well
we knew that both you and Kevin are
guitar enthusiasts so we asked you to
bring your guitar and kevin has his here
and we're hoping that right alright let
us through to the commercial we're back
with more of the show but for now we
want to listen to something
and
I want to hear you say something the
food is monotonous there's nothing to
drink
and chicks don't come here what you sit
there but I fire the Rockets that is a
blast throw out the dishes and I never
cut the grass cuz I'm here
I'm on top tired
taking the time get back got the world
on a string its people